mais d'abord gros plan sur le vote
protestataire et son influence
prévisible sur ce scrutin avec
pierre-henri holder bamba a voté depuis
plusieurs années le vote protestataire
ne cesse d'augmenter atteignant 2017 les
79 % au premier tour des électeurs
inscrits pour le directeur du cevipof de
critères renforce cette contestation il
ya une dimension el sheikh et
objectivables c'est à dire des électeurs
qui sont profondément insatisfait de la
vie qu'ils mènent que le politique ne
veut pas changer leur destin individuel
deuxième dimension plus subjective on
est dans les affects où finalement ce
sentiment que le vote l'acte de vote
l'instrument de vote ne ne rend pas
totalement con de la possibilité de
faire confiance aux représentants élus
pour le premier tour les intentions de
vote en faveur des candidats
protestataires semblent se renforcer à
gauche 17% en moyenne pour jean luc
mélenchon et à droite autour des 21%
pour marine le pen 9% pour eric zemmour
a deux raisons pour lesquelles on peut
être amené à voter pour des forces
politiques qui apparaissent comme les
taux aux extrêmes la première c'est la
forme de clarté du propos est le
deuxième aspect c'est qu'il y a
également contrairement à ce qu'on peut
appeler les partis traditionnels du
gouvernement le sentiment qu'il une
forme d'unité alors qu'on a pu voir par
exemple que du côté du parti socialiste
d'un côté du côté des républicains de
l'autre qu'il n'y a plus à voir défendre
de tensions internes à chacune des
formations politiques ce qui a nui à
l'image du ou de la candidate l'image et
emmanuel macron en prend également un
coup en raison d'une annonce de
candidature tardive et de l'opposition
qui lui reprochent de ne pas vouloir
débattre le fait de ne pas entrer en
campagne très très tôt a été
utilisé comme une une marque de fond de
défiance et puis j'irai aussi eu une
marque de non-respect
du de la séquence politique le fait
qu'il donne le sentiment de pas
véritablement vouloir faire campagne
non seulement ils ne sont pas présents
dans les débats mais ne sont pas
présents un certain nombre d'émissions
politiques ou qu'on ne voit pas ni en
meeting ni au contact des citoyens a
renforcé l'idée que certains candidats
pouvaient être plus en prise entre
guillemets avec le peuple et c'est
l'état notamment de man le pen d'un côté
et de jeunechamp de l'impact de la
guerre en ukraine reste à l'avantagé des
manuels macron puisqu'une étude de la
fondapol révèle que 62% des sondés sont
satisfaits de sa gestion et qu'aucun de
ses concurrents n'est jugée capable de
pouvoir mieux la conduire
zoom sur ce vote contestataire avec mes
invités dominique reynié bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directeur général de
la fondation pour l'innovation politique
qui publie son rapport 2022
présidentielle de crise anne charlène
bezina bonsoir vous avancez maître de
conférences en droit public j'accueille
également pierre jacqmin bonsoir soit
l'acteur en chef de la revue regards on
est en duplex avec pierre latry chef de
groupe chez ipsos bon soit pire la
tournée de ce qu'est notre partenaire
pour les soirées électorales sur public
sénat et lcp et matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique bonsoir mathieu
de lui crier je commence avec vous et
avec votre rapport le rapport de la
fondapol bon lucas il ya cette idée
d'une persistance d'une amplification du
vote protestataire mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un phénomène
que vous étudiez que vous analysez
depuis depuis combien de temps
d'ailleurs
ça a commencé en 2004 avec en fait même
c2c intéressant parce que la première
étude là dessus ça s'appelle la france
en des prêts en dépression électorale
c'était janvier 2002 sur la
présidentielle de 2002 où avec mon
collègue jean chiche en tournée des
indicateurs et environ 10 et que ça
n'allait pas bien se passer au premier
tour on n'était pas en mesure de dire
que le second tour serait celui qui l'a
été mais les indicateurs qu'on voit
depuis en fait ça a commencé même je
pense moi 1988 pour moi c'est le point
de départ c'est à dire le pen 14 4% et
puis ensuite ça n'a pas cessé de prendre
de l'ampleur à droite à gauche et quand
il ya une contre performance comme en
2007 jean-marie le pen un peu au dessus
de 10 il y avait auparavant
en 2000 en 2005 un référendum qui avait
envoyé balader une partie des médias la
classe politique de gouvernement à 55% à
tout un bouleversement rien en fait n'a
été rétablie restaurer réparer
cicatriser à chaque fois c'est plutôt
une étape supplémentaire et on va
rentrer évidemment de rentrer dans le
détail et dans dans l'analyse anne-marie
vézina c'est l'un des symptômes d'une
démocratie ne va pas bien démocratie
malade c'est l'un des symptômes des
démocraties en ce moment c'est sallie
est un peu angoissant c'est qu'on vit en
plus une guerre en ukraine qui nous fait
comprendre que la démocratie face à
l'autocratie a quand même beaucoup de
souci à se faire puisque comme le
principe de la démocratie c'est de
laisser parler tout le monde alors que
l'autocratie ne choisit c'est ses
manières de penser et bien en fait il ya
tout lieu de penser c'est les
démocraties qui vont mourir face à face
aux autocraties et le grand risque à
craindre à mon ami de cette guerre là
c'est justement qu'elle s'allie dans une
certaine manière de gouverner et que
cette manière de gouverner et du succès
d'ailleurs parce que finalement dans
cette présidentielle ce dont on se rend
compte j'ai l'impression c'est que le
politique n'arrive plus vraiment à avoir
accès aux citoyens pourquoi votre ton
c'était c'était le général de gaulle qui
disait ça en 58 et on vote pour changer
ses conditions de vie on voit pour
changer quelque chose de son quotidien
et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le vote
présidentiel en tout cas arrive à
répondre à cette question la réponse
malheureusement pour le moment alors le
premier tour n'a pas encore eu lieu donc
on espère se tromper mais d'après les
indicateurs qu'on en a le sentiment que
le politique n'arrive plus vraiment à
être la réponse aux manettes des
français on est on est même plus dans
cette vague de populisme qu'on a pu
voilà où commençait à dater de 2013-14
ça dépend un petit peu des élections et
des pays mais on est dans une vague
c'est pierre rosanvallon qu on parle
comme ça d'individualisme c'est à dire
que finalement c'est les querelles des
uns et de l'alliance autour des
querelles des uns et les querelles des
autres qui font qu'on salue donc c'est
le boom des associations
ddd presque d'aidé courrier du coeur
mais plus vraiment des partis politiques
pierre jacqmin on sait on va l'analyser
qu'il ya une porosité entre l'électorat
de marine le pen il suit jean luc
mélenchon mais qu'elle ference vous vous
faites l epa surtout l'électorat sur une
partie de lectorat quelle différence
vous vous faites entre ces votes
protestataires
j'ai lu la tête de l'étude avec beaucoup
d'attention parce que il ya énormément
d'enseignements et d'ailleurs quelques
enseignements assez optimiste parce que
tout n'est pas que négatif un joli coup
notamment 85 % jugent encore utile
d'aller voter ou même le rapport à
l'europe la croissance dans la confiance
des institutions européennes tout ça
c'est des éléments qui participent quand
même je trouve à des éléments qu'il
faudrait mettre en valeur quand même
tout n'est pas que négatif et j'ai eu un
petit et questions des interrogations
qui me sont venues en lisant aussi
l'étude c'est ce fameux vote
protestataire celui que vous considérez
comme étant un vrai de prostate aux
terres face à des candidats
protestataires j'ai le sentiment qu'on
est moins en face à un vote
protestataire ont des candidats
protestataires que des candidats et un
électorat qui est sensible à une rupture
nécessaire vous voyez le vote des jeunes
tous dit très longue dans votre étude
c'est que le vote des jeunes de plus en
plus je crois que c'est 54 % des 18-24
ans vous dites dans l'étude que ces
jeunes-là seraient attirés par ce vote
protestataire ou en tout cas par des
candidats protestataires ces jeunes là
j'ai le sentiment en tout cas que ce
sont des jeunes qui se sont beaucoup
mobilisés notamment pour les marchands
climat et qui demande une rupture et
c'est vrai que jean luc mélenchon marine
le pen provoque en tout cas dans leurs
discours le sentiment que s'il était en
responsabilité crée des ruptures l'une
en exclusion on va parler le phénomène
d'exclusion et beaucoup dans l'exclusion
la responsabilité des étrangers en
permanence jean luc mélenchon plus sous
la halle à la rupture avec un système
dominant qui serait le capitalisme qui
serait un monde très bureaucratique et
c'est donc j'ai plus ce sentiment en
tout cas dans la rhétorique qui est
celle que vous utilisez dans ce dans ce
2e set c'était une très intéressante me
pose question c'est qu'on a le sentiment
de voir la protestation là où
précisément il y aurait une aspiration à
un changement un changement de cap
d'un électorat qui n'est pas
dépolitiser parce que c'est aussi ça
l'étude beaucoup vont s'abstenir ce
qu'on dit dans l'étude mais que c'est
ils ont une conscience politique et que
leur vote protégés derrière ce qu'on
appelle vote protestataire ya peut-être
aussi un vote d'adhésion pour un
changement de modèle alors qu'elle a
changé c'est que ces candidats sont en
mesure peut-être d'accéder au second
tour et en mesure peut-être de se faire
dire ce qui change quand même beaucoup
la donne par rapport des votes
protestataires qu'on a pu connaître lors
de scrutins précédents il ya dix ans il
ya vingt ans où on avait un vote pour
pousser un coup de gueule ou ses
candidats étaient des réceptacles de
colère étaient des portelois de
dénonciation d'indignation mais il
n'était pas question dans la tête des
gens que ces gens-là accès d'un jour aux
responsabilités là on a une offre qui
s'inscrit dans cette tradition
protestataires et qui offre des champs à
chacune un changement de paradigme
vous l'avez dit le père jacques nouard
jean luc mélenchon propose un changement
de paradigme institutionnel économique
et écologique social bref c'est un
changement et marine le pen propose elle
aussi un vrai changement de paradigme
par rapport à la société dans laquelle
on vit aujourd'hui par rapport à ce que
notre modèle de politique donc on est
passé de la protestation d'une certaine
façon à la transformation pour l'instant
il ya toujours ce plafond de verre qui
fait que ces candidats protestataires
n'ont jamais pu être en mesure de
rassembler 50% des voix plus une au
second tour mais je la façon dont on les
regarde la façon dont on place on ne
soient nos espoirs notre détestation a
quand même beaucoup changé parce que ils
sont vraiment aux portes du pouvoir
alors je vous donne la parole à pierre
latry on va regarder d'abord pierre le
dernier sondage ce que vous proposez
avec sopra steria pour france info et le
le parisien où on voit je parlais dans
mes titres de ce trio de tête ce ça se
confirme jour après jour on a une
emmanuel macron à 27% intention de vote
marine le pen 22 jean luc mélenchon à 17
puis ensuite il ya un deuxième groupe
eric zemmour valérie pécresse yannick
jadot et ensuite on a des candidats en
dessous des dessins qui est même des
quatre fabien roussel jean lassalle anne
hidalgo nicolas dupont aignan philippe
poutou et nathalie arthaud je vous
propose j'ai je reviens sur les
questions de la porosité des électrodes
si finalement vous n'avez pas encore
répondu mais
vous allez pouvoir collectivement y
répondre et avant d'entendre pierre
latry là dessus on écoute jean luc
mélenchon alors c'est dans son meeting
meeting hologramme là où il était
physiquement à l'idée de démultiplier
dans plusieurs villes de de france il
s'adresse très clairement aux électeurs
et aux électrices de marine le pen il
les appelle les fâcher pas facho écoutez
écoutez vous autres les fâcher quête pas
facho à la fin il s'avoue même cette
histoire de porte d'essayer porter cette
femme au pouvoir
ou y trouvez-vous quoi que ce soit dans
ce qu'elle dit ou ce qu'elle fait qu'ils
ne soient pas entièrement teinté
d'une sorte de mépris
de classe
pierre latry il reste quatre jours avant
le premier tour la question je sais pas
si la réponse est facile mais est ce que
jean luc mélenchon avec cette stratégie
peut reprendre cinq fois marine le pen
en aussi peu de temps
ça paraît un petit peu compliqué quand
même il faut pas oublier déjà que le
clivage droite gauche conserve une
certaine forme de réalité pour les
électorats et que donc ce n'est pas
forcément si simple que ça d'attirer à
lui des électeurs
de des électeurs de marine le pen
ensuite la deuxième chose qu'il est
important de noter je reviens du coup un
petit peu sur ce que vous disiez avant
c'est que ya dans le vote protestataire
et dans le vote pour les candidats
protestataires un vote d'adhésion aussi
aujourd'hui quand on interroge les
électeurs potentiels sur est-ce que ce
vote est un vote d'adhésion un vote par
défaut les deux candidats qui ont le
plus de votes d'adhésion c'est eric
zemmour et marine le pen donc ça veut
quand même dire qu'aujourd'hui on a 70 %
des électeurs de potentiel de marine le
pen qui votent pour elle par adhésion et
je les vois mal en fait allé sur la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon
d'autant plus que les derniers sondages
semblent eux
donnelly accréditer l'idée que elle a de
bonnes chances d'être au second tour et
qui est un vote utile en sa faveur
dominique reynié sur 7 je repose un peu
la même question sur la la korité où les
différences entre ces votes
protestataires celui qui va plutôt vers
un marine le pen et un humour et celui
qui va plutôt vers jean luc mélenchon
d'abord dans le plongement de ce qui a
été dit moi je crois qu'un effet nous
avons une transformation du type de
clivage avec comme arrière fond un
clivage droite gauche qui demeure tout à
fait d'accord avec cette remarque mais
qui est une sorte de face à face entre
une option de réforme est une option de
rupture au fond les réformes droite
gauche on les a vécues dans l'alternance
y compris dans les cohabitations on est
arrivé au bout de cela probablement il
ya 20 ans 2002 maintenant c'est plutôt
la question de savoir si c'est une
rupture ou une réforme qui se continue
et aussi ça signifie est-ce que l'on
voie vers la confrontation entre nous
parce que nous n'arrivons pas décidément
à nous comprendre où est ce qu'on est
capable de fabriquer un compromis c'est
ça qui est désormais nous sommes passés
dans cette étape là et je crois que
quand on regarde les intentions de vote
qu'on fait le total des candidats de
rupture on est autour de 50% donc c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est
historique
c'est dominé par un vote de rupture de
droite
avec une droite
pour plus distincts qui tout à fait et
qui a atteint des niveaux qui n'avaient
jamais été connue dans cette autre
histoire républicaine
et elles le font de cette adhésion là il
repose quand même très largement sur
doudou le vote d'adhésion sur un
sentiment qu'il y a des grandes
questions qu'il faut absolument traité
l'immigration l'intégration la sécurité
la place de l'islam en france ça ce sont
des sujets extrêmement importants qui
font adhérer cet électorat et qui le
rendre disponible
meyer constante et sur quoi bien sûr
jean luc mélenchon ne peut rien d'où la
porosité il convient alors que
l'électorat de marine le pen accès 40 %
des ouvriers votre marine le pen donc
les autres s'abstient en gros pour aller
vite les employés votre marine le pen y
les classes populaires votent marine le
pen et donc si l'usc jean luc mélenchon
est beaucoup plus oui considère l'on a
deux fois plus que celle beaucoup plus
dans la totalité c'est le plus qu'elle
mais le vote numéro un chez les ouvriers
les employés c'est marine le pen il est
très très loin ça veut dire que comment
faire pour qu'une gauche y compris de
rupture se reconstruise où existent dans
un contexte où les classes populaires
votent à la droite populiste c'est
compliqué alors pour les transferts de
voix je n'y crois pas dans ce sens là
dans l'autre sens on le verra au second
tour entre les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon et marine l'allalin c'est bien
ce que vous nous dit-on on regarde un
toujours dans cette émission on essaye
de prendre un peu plus de recul et on
regarde les tendances tient sur trois
semaines sur à propos du trio de tête
évolution sur trois semaines pour
emmanuel macron donc et donc à 27 dans
le dernier à ipsos il perd 4 points
marine le pen est à 22 elle en gagne 6
jean luc mélenchon en est à 17 il en
gagne
5,6 si je provoquais un petit peu en
shearling bezina je dirais heureusement
que le premier tour et dans quatre jours
pour emmanuel macron quoi alors c'est
vrai que pour emmanuel macron il ya il
ya trois choses il ya une première c'est
la question de l'effet drapeau
finalement avec cette guerre en ukraine
on a eu ce sentiment qu'on a déjà eu en
france un sous la troisième république
ça avait profité aussi à mitterrand
pendant la guerre du koweït c'est l'idée
de voilà d'avoir une nation unie et
finalement on a mis un petit peu de côté
les querelles partisanes dans ce moment
un peu internationale mais cette guerre
étant amenée à durer finalement cet
effet là c'est complètement il faudrait
donc la première a constaté à mon avis
est que cet effet de la d'unité
nationale qu'on a pu vivre après des
attentats ou ces choses là il vient et
complètement aujourd'hui évaporée la
deuxième c'est que on peut lui reprocher
finalement dans cette campagne éclair et
heureusement qu'elle a été éclair pour
lui parce qu'on sait pas finalement
comment ça aurait terminé si elle avait
été plus long mais dans cette campagne
éclair il a quand même fait un succédané
de quelques erreurs qu'il a un petit peu
faire durant tout son quinquennat c'est
à dire cette idée d'apparaître un petit
peu en unilatéralité c'est à dire de
proposer des choses tout en acceptant
pas nécessairement d'être placé au même
plan et il a joué sur la posture
d'anciens présidents mais on peut
peut-être lui reprocher aussi de ne pas
avoir lui même fait une campagne
individuelles plus poussés par exemple
les anciens présidents comme nicolas
sarkozy qui sait représenter en 2012 a
certes refusé des débats mais déjà on
avait proposé 2 ou 3 au second tour s'il
y était et en plus avait lui même fait
des meetings s'était présenté un petit
peu au peuple alors que là il ya eu un
peu cette idée de voile à ne pas se
présenter ce qui a pu donner le
sentiment que c'était déjà acquis la
troisième je n'avais pas fait un petit
peu de meetings leurs effets 40e
sa campagne présidentielle alors
pourquoi j'ai un petit peu parce qu'elle
a quand même été très courte c'est vrai
dans le temps sa campagne mais comme
vous le dites elle a été émaillée de
beaucoup de meetings très cher qui
comptait beaucoup la troisième chose
c'est que finalement il a aujourd'hui
les conséquences de ce qu'il a créé en
2010 est c'est à dire d'avoir
complètement brisée l'échiquier
politique il faut le dire moi je suis
pas forcément sûr d'être d'accord avec
l'idée qu'on se positionne encore à
droite et à gauche parce que je ne sais
pas si on peut vraiment qualifier marine
le pen de candidate de droite voire
d'extrême droite parce que quand on
analyse la plupart de ses propositions
et c'est une enquête café cevipof
d'ailleurs et bien en fait depuis des
années 90 le front national est
aujourd'hui le rassemblement national
vous cherchez quand même alors électeurs
je vous interromps là dessus parce que
c'est justement le thème de la chronique
de matthieu croissandeau avec thé avec
cette question non mais c'est bien ça
avance à la perquisition marine le pen
est elle toujours d'extrême droite
mathieu oui si on se pose la question
aujourd'hui c'est bien que c'est moins
évident d'y répondre qu'il ya quelques
années en tout cas qu'avant d'extrême
droite l'est originellement frappe
familialement j'allais dire le front
national de son père auprès duquel la
fois elle s'est formée dès logiquement
auprès duquel elle a milité auprès
duquel elle s'est construit
politiquement ce front national là ils
s'inscrivaient dans la longue tradition
d'extrême droite française on rappelle
que d'un point de vue historique se sont
défaits 1 il a été fondé par ordre
nouveau qui est un parti néo fasciste
pour être sa vitrine électorale en 1972
ont traditionnellement historiquement ça
vient de là le problème c'est que depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans le marine le
pen qui exclut son père qui a transformé
assez profondément la doctrine qui a
rebaptisé son mouvement rassemblement
national elle réfute l'étiquette
d'extrême droite qu'elle juge aussi
infamante que fos le travail de diable
de dédiabolisation qu'elle a entamée et
approfondie depuis cinq ans on l'a
encore à la fois sur le fond et sur la
forme à brouiller encore un peu plus les
repères et puis l'éruption sur la scène
politique d'un eric zemmour plus à
droite plus radicale plus extrêmes plus
brno fob à recentrer defacto marine le
pen ce matin dans le figaro elle réfute
encore cette étiquette expliquant que le
paysage politique s'est recomposé entre
nationaux et post nationaux donc ce
qu'est une autre lecture que droite
gauche avec une phrase qu'elle dit c'est
quand même une dialectique extrêmement
vintage cette façon de crier au loup
sans jamais les théiers est datée c'est
une forme de res intellectuelle du
système emmanuel macron jouent sur les
peurs il va désormais devoir revoir son
argumentation ces îlots pose en continu
de l'attaquer sur le fond mais justement
ils ont du mal emmanuel macron le
premier un pur naïma il ya une semaine à
fouras et dit oui pourquoi la presse ne
dit plus qu'à l'extrême droite attention
vas-y réveil ce sera paul à et quand on
lui demande qu'est ce qui se serait
passé c'est l'extrême droite était
arrivée ou qu'est-ce qui se passerait si
l'arrivée il dit mais c'est avaient été
élus les français ont été vaccinés et
des vaccinés versez un peu court quand
même pour qualifier le parti d'extrême
droite alors qu'il ya sans doute
d'autres raisons de le faire prenez jean
luc mélenchon vient d'entendre lui l'a
attendu le son dernier meeting pour
cible et marine le pen il ne l'avait pas
fait avant et qu'est-ce qu'il dit
s'adresse aux électeurs en disant cette
fameuse formule qui date de 2017 les
fâcher pas facho mais facile les
électeurs de marine le pen sont fâchés
pas facho après tout pourquoi elle ne
serait pas elle aussi fâché et pas facho
l'argument il est il est à double sens
et alors si on va dans le programme
maintenant alors dans son programme il
existe bien derrière les mesures
sociales derrière les mesures pour la
cause animale isme dernière tout une
sorte de patchwork de mesures qu avec un
caprice marine le pen il reste des
marqueurs d'extrême droite la préférence
nationale rebaptisé aux priorités
nationales c'est bien une mesure de
discrimination à l'encontre des
étrangers qui vivent sur notre sol
le contournement du conseil
constitutionnel je parle sous le
contrôle d'une juriste sûr à travers le
recours au référendum sur l'immigration
s'est vu par certains
constitutionnalistes comme une forme de
coup d'état institutionnel puisque ce
n'est pas dans l'esprit en tout cas de
la constitution sa remise en cause des
médias on peut dire c'est qu'elle veut
privatiser l'audiovisuel public ça a
remise ce mépris d'une certaine façon
des corps intermédiaires pas franchement
une très bonne vision 10 des très bons
rapports avec les syndicats tout ça est
aussi surtout ses alliances européennes
avec ses inspirations avec les
démocraties ont dit libéral donc celle
de viktor orban on cite souvent
évidemment hongrie mais ces alliances
avec des partis de l'extrême droite à la
pologne mais c'est par des alliances
avec des partis d'extrême droite
européens sont sa fascination jadis
parce que tout a changé
l'avenir plume et l'admiré c'est vrai
vladimir poutine
pourquoi verbalement voilà tout ça
s'inscrit dans cette veine d'extrême
droite bref marine le pen a changé c'est
vrai elle à lisser son image est adouci
son discours c'est vrai aussi il faut le
reconnaître il ya des totems qu'elle a
abandonné je pense à la suppression de
la faim voulait supprimer la double
nationalité puis elle est revenue dessus
par exemple voulait quitter la
conscience des vrais hommes et voilà je
parle d'un point de vue extrêmes droites
sortir l'union peut être souverainiste
n'est pas forcement être décret mais ces
marqueurs là les abandonner mais n'a pas
pour autant abandonné tous les ferments
autoritaire en fête nationaliste
xénophobe qui continuent d'être des
fondamentaux de son parti allez je vous
lance là-dessus pierre jacqmin marine le
pen est-elle d'extrême droite est-ce
qu'il faut arrêter d'avoir des pudeurs
de jeune fille ou de rentrer dans sa
communication d'une certaine façon on
peut aussi l'analyse est comme ça et je
n'ai aucune pudeur a assuré affirmé en
tout cas que marine le pen reste une
personnalité d'extrême droite qui a
qui qui est à la tête d'une formation
politique d'extrême droite jusqu'à il ya
peu de temps elle avait encore autour
d'elle des groupuscules
d'extrême droite néo nazis il ya des
amitiés avec des groupes qui ont été
dissous récemment je pense à génération
identitaire c'est trop composition de la
famille d'extrême droite va sans doute
peut-être joué à la faveur de marine le
pen parce que beaucoup ont suivi éric
zemmour parce que lui assumer le
discours du père de marine le pen père
fin de jean marie le pen pardon dit lui
assumer un discours beaucoup plus
radicale beaucoup plus ouvertement
raciste que ne le fait marine le pen
marine le pen elle a fait très
habilement une campagne sur le social en
jouant sur ce qui est entre eux ce qui
ressort de votre étude aussi la
préoccupation des français 59% c'est le
pouvoir d'achat elle a fait sa campagne
là dessus elle à sensibiliser les
français sur cela et elle a
effectivement elle s'est normalisée
banalisée mais il faut pas oublier une
chose quand même c'est que les
politiques qui ont été conduits aussi je
pense notamment à celle des modèles
maquereau ou même précédemment avec
cette ferme quinquennat sur la déchéance
de nationalité il ya une légitimation
politique de 10 du discours d'extrême
droite donc ce qu'on appelait jadis
justement ce discours d'extrême droite a
été légitimée par des lois comme la loi
l immigration la loi séparatisme et le
rageux rappel à loi sur la déchéance de
nationalité donc on a oublié que tout ça
c'était des fondamentaux en tout cas des
d'aider nos idées des idées qui venait
quand même de l'extrême droite donc
marine le pen a réussi sept lepénisation
de la classe politique et en même temps
sans doute aussi il faut bien le
reconnaître peut-être marine le pen a
aussi évolué elle a évolué sur les
questions sociétales on a une sans doute
mais le fond du fond de ce qu'est le
rassemblement national reste un parti
profondément d'extrême droite ça c'est
certain pierre latry comment vous quand
vous sonder l'opinion là que
quotidiennement et depuis plusieurs
semaines pour pour ipsos que comment s
il ya toujours des des facteurs de rejet
malgré tout très fort qui étaient les
facteurs de rejet associé à une
personnalité ou une candidate d'extrême
droite pour marine le pen on parle pas
dire est que ces morts-là oui tout à
fait tout à fait c'est vraiment un
élément qu'il faut pas négliger alors
effectivement on a vu une image qui ces
lycées petit à petit pendant la campagne
elle fait moins peur notamment parce
qu'eric zemmour a aussi incarner une
droite beaucoup plus radicale mais elle
est encore perçue comme une candidate
d'extrême droite par la grande majorité
des français quand on leur demande de
situer de 1 à 10 un étang la gauche
disent la droite quand même 66% la
mettre entre 9 et 10 donc vous voyez
qu'elle est encore perçue comme une
candidate d'extrême droite elle continue
inquiétait beaucoup de gens aient
effectivement peut-être qu'ils aient
moins de centraliser l'attention sur
l'extrême droite la plus radicale et a
été perçue comme peut-être le candidat
le plus radical mais si elle se retrouve
second tour face à emmanuel macron lui
ne sera plus là et l'inquiétude
vis-à-vis de son positionnement à elle
risque à mon avis de ressortir et on
voit qu'elle continue à être une source
d'inquiétude pour un grand nombre de
français dominique reynié ce jeu vous
écoutez ce matin ce mercredi matin sur
sur rtl avec yves calvi dans un débat
qui était qui était passionnant c'est
pas un terme que vous employez forcément
vous disiez la droite de la droite
vous qualifiez le pen extrêmement la
difficulté c'est extrême droite c'est
une catégorie politique de dénonciation
que toute sa légitimité et sa raison
d'être
et quand on veut l'appliquer dans la
description objective d'un d'un
phénomène politique on leur met en
difficulté un critère
de l'extrême droite c'est la remise en
cause de l'ordre démocratique on ne
trouve pas alors on peut dire que c'est
dans l'intention c'est possible c'est
donc c'est discuter de l'intention de le
référendum pour voter une loi qui
permettrait de contourner le conseil
constituerait vous avez vous avez le
curseur à très sensible parce que si
vous regardez chez mélenchon
général de gaulle
lui même enfin les bons coups même dit
on peut même discuté de la possibilité
c'est comme la privatisation de
l'audiovisuel public vous avez des
libéraux qui le proposent ça donc à
chaque fois calmé la contestation des
grands tribunaux comme la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme ce
genre de 2,2 d'institutions qui sont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas la faveur de marine le
pen participe quand même dans sentiments
on se dit marine le pen président de
république qui quand même long terme de
démocratie on va avoir un sujet ses
serments un marqueur de l'extrême droite
ce sont les catégorisations jean yves
camus c'est de toute façon les
définitions elles ont beaucoup changé de
ce que c'est que l'extrême droite rit
parce que il ya des populistes de gauche
qui proposent la sortie de toutes les
conventions internationales possible
mais alors il ya un terme qu'on a
employé plusieurs fois sur ce plateau
dans nos débats et qu'il faut bien
prononcé l'hedim des démocraties
libérales
on rompt la france rentrerait peut-être
dans cette catégorie en charge de bezina
cie marine le pen mais je ne sais pas
mais à l'instant oui alors c'est c'est
alors moi je suis pas sur ce concept de
démocratie il libérales etc c'est
vraiment une question qu'on a entre
politologue fonctionnaliste existe
vraiment parce que pour moi une
démocratie est fondée sur le dogme du
libéralisme et des libertés politiques
on a dit cette phrase qui a été attribué
à à un président des états unis mais qui
en réalité vient d'aristote la
démocratie pour le peuple par le peuple
avec le peuple donc comment penser une
démocratie par l'idh libéralisme alors
pour moi c'est juste pour ces démocratie
autoritaire pour ces régimes
autoritaires un habillage qui consiste à
dire mais non voyez nous continuons à
être démocrate et à et à solliciter des
élections qui n'ont pas d'opposition qui
n'ont aucune légitimité qui ne sont pas
d'ailleurs la commission de venise qui
examine ces différents procédés
électoraux non valide pas un seul sur
les sur les différents jeux france à la
hongrie la pologne et c'est donc moi ce
concept de démocratie libérale j'ai
quand même déjà beaucoup de mal et oui
en effet si nous rentrions dans une
france d'eric zemmour dans une france 2
marine le pen et je vais plus loin
peut-être dans la 6ème république de
jean luc mélenchon nous mettrions
sûrement à mal beaucoup des dogmes
historique de la france libérale et
démocratique parce que à partir du
moment où on prétend que le pouvoir
appartient au peuple et que du coup
toutes les institutions doivent être
court circuiter pour moi c'est mettre
fin en effet au dogme de la démocratie
et souvent on né peut on oppose
justement un petit peu la démocratie
directe c'est-à-dire le fait que le
peuple
c'est un peu le discours de marine le
pen eric zemmour de dire mais non on va
redonner la parole au peuple etc mais
c'est le principe à mon avis d'un
populisme c'est à dire de vouloir parler
aux émotions au lieu de parler
finalement à l'intelligence politique de
cette population là et je crois que ces
discours là ont une responsabilité dans
la déconnexion de nos partis politiques
et des citoyens avec les partis
politiques si on ne vote plus
aujourd'hui c'est parce que on nous a
appris il ya cette phrase quand même de
bp griggio qui était un élu italien qui
disait moi je la politique ne
m'intéresse pas je veux parler à votre
émotionnel et moi je crois c'est ça qui
qui est plus grave dans ce que nous
allons
donc ce qu'il faudra changer à mon avis
de la république au niveau de la
république la vème république on a parlé
d un des six a rejoint finalement ce que
ce que vous disiez grâce à marion vie au
grand soir marion vous pouvez nous
rejoindre sur le plateau de sens public
bienvenue donc c'est une population
entre guillemets assez hétérogène
finalement ces indécis effectivement il
ya trois types d'indécis il ya tout
d'abord ceux qui hésitent entre la
participation est l'abstention il ya
ceux qui ont prévu d'aller voter mais
qui ne savent pas encore pour quel
candidat et puis il ya ceux qui hésitent
entre plusieurs candidats selon une
enquête publiée aujourd'hui par le
cevipof 68 % des électeurs sont
aujourd'hui sûrs de leur choix et 32%
hésitent encore et fêter de constater
que selon les camps ces positions
varient ainsi les partisans d' emmanuel
macron de marine le pen et d'eric
zemmour seconde certains de leur vote
qu'ils sont dans l'ordre 82 78 75 % à ne
pas hésiter pour le premier tour c'est
en revanche plus compliqué pour valérie
pécresse mais aussi pour l'ensemble des
candidats de gauche jean luc mélenchon y
compris ils sont le concernant encore 34
% à estimer que leur choix peut encore
varier d'où les appels récents et
répétées du candidat de la france
insoumise dans ses meetings à la
mobilisation et à la participation dans
cette dernière ligne droite de cette
campagne ces électeurs flottants
deviennent la cible des candidats car on
voit bien qu'ils représentent un
réservoir de voix non négligeable et
alors si on regarde un peu plus loin
dans le rétroviseur marion commence
cette indécision a évolué dans le temps
et bien depuis 2002 les chercheurs
observent une décision électoral qui est
effectivement de plus en plus tardive en
2012 par exemple 11% des électeurs elle
s'était décidée le jour du scrutin et
sur ses décisions tardives je vous
propose d'écouter un martial foucault le
directeur du cevipof
2022 comparativement à la 2017 on est
sensiblement sur les mêmes niveaux
petite progression de l'indécision donc
aujourd'hui à une semaine du scrutin
lorsqu'on a mené cette enquête nous
avons un nombre considérable d'électeurs
qui sont toujours indécis et bien
souvent ce choix de vote va se faire
dans les dernières heures voire même sur
le chemin du but ce vote est ce qui rend
très difficile de d'indiquer que le
rapport de force politique est
totalement stabilisée nom et ses sources
très souvent comme une surprise dans le
niveau des intentions de vote alors en
2017 les écarts entre les candidats au
premier tour étaient très faibles et ses
électeurs indécis aurait pu faire
basculer le scrutin notamment en faveur
de jean-luc mélenchon ou de françois
fillon éliminé au premier tour qui était
pourtant à peu près un point de marine
le pen cette année pour l'instant des
écarts entre les candidats restent
importants on pourrait se dire que c'est
un des six ne vont pas peser mais comme
la campagne se fait au dernier moment et
que le taux d'abstention est annoncé
comme important il y a encore beaucoup
de scénarios possibles je terminerai par
les raisons cette indécision selon cj
peuvent elles seraient davantage lié à
la profusion de mesures d' annonce des
candidats de débats durant cette
campagne et les professions de foi qui
sont en train d'arriver au domicile vont
être étudiés de près par les indécis et
il suffira alors pour eux d'une phrase
d'une mesure proche de leurs
préoccupations pour enclencher un vote
définitif merci marion je reprends la
l'un des chiffres que marion vernoux
données pierre latry
32 % des électeurs français qui hésitent
encore ça ne facilite pas votre travail
ça non j'ai effectivement ça complique
un petit peu parce qu'on voit bien qu
une partie des électeurs devront sans
doute se décider à la dernière minute
peut-être même se décider sur le fait
d'aller voter ou non ça complique un
petit peu les choses et on va surtout
effectivement c'est à gauche on vous
l'avait dit que le colin décision est la
plus forte ce phénomène de vote utile en
faveur de jean-luc mélenchon favorise
peut être aussi une forme d' indécision
c'est à dire qu'une partie de
l'électorat de gauche aujourd'hui ils
dit vraiment entre jean luc mélenchon il
ya ni pour les électeurs de yannick
jadot et yannick jadot donc cesser ou
pour pareil pour fabien roussel donc ça
complique un petit peu les choses et ça
risque effectivement on pourrait avoir
une surprise sur le score de jean luc
mélenchon au soir du premier tour vu que
on toute une partie de son électorat
n'est pas encore tout à fait certain la
dominique reynié ce trio de tête il peut
arriver dans un ordre différent ça
certainement jeu il faut il faut garder
cette prudence l'a en tout cas
d'enfoncement dix à quatre jours du
scrutin certains et c'est pas une
formule de style mais il ya aussi
quelque chose qui m'étonne je trouve
qu'on ne prend pas assez en
considération les changements d'époque
par exemple la question sur la certitude
du choix électoral elle se pose depuis
toujours faim depuis toujours
c'est-à-dire depuis qu'existe une joute
présidentielle
se noue mais aujourd'hui n'a pas le même
sens parce que c'est un niveau
d'information constants or nous sommes
dans une phase
d'événements au pluriel il se passe des
choses beaucoup et c'est pas tout à fait
d'aujourd'hui mais ce n'est pas si vieux
que cela que nous avons maintenant c'est
la première élection présidentielle
en crise ça ne s'est jamais produit et
donc il peut y avoir des événements il y
en a tous les jours qui affecte la
décision l'intention de voter de
l'électeur et même je prends deux fait
tout simple mais on a un président la
république qui vous disiez qui s'est
déclarée très très tard la décision va
commencer à partir du moment où il est
candidat on peut avoir l'intention de
voter pour lui mais on attend de voir
s'il se déclare du comment il le fait on
a un candidat commun moore qui est un
nouveau dans la troupe est donc ça
suspens le jugement ça peut amener à le
préférer puis à se reporter ailleurs si
on ne prend que ces éléments là il ya
des raisons singulière propre cette
élection d'avoir une sorte d'
incertitudes sur la décision électorale
et donc dans les quelques jours qui nous
séparent du scrutin y compris dans la
décision que nous n'avons pas assez
souligné entre aller voter ou ne pas
aller voter si passion abstentions il y
aura inévitablement de grandes de grands
mouvements mais il faut dire aussi aux
téléspectateurs que les mouvements ils
peuvent être très importants et ne pas
produire de résultats qui se voit
puisque si vous avez un mouvement
d'abstentionnistes compenser leur
mouvement de participation vous avez le
même taux alors qu'en fait il ya eu
énormément de changements chez les
électeurs il est de même pour les
changements entre les candidats je reste
avec vous parce que dans votre rapport
il ya aussi la question de l' influence
de la guerre en ukraine sur le vote qui
est quand même assez importante vous
l'évaluez une façon assez important oui
c'est pratiquement sûrs d'eux nous dit
que ça racontait dans sa réflexion plus
d'un quart de plus d'un quart ont dit
que ça le gêne dans sa réflexion parce
que ça écrase quand même nos débats
derrière cette cet événement
considérable cette tragédie nous sommes
tous témoins c'est d'ailleurs les mêmes
qui nous disent à 62% ça a été rappelé
que emmanuel macron à gérer de manière
satisfaisante cette crise qu'aucun
candidat aurait fait mieux ça veut pas
dire que vous aurez fait moins bien mais
aucun aurait fait mieux que lui donc
soyez pas beaucoup redoutent considèrent
que la guerre est très importante ont
peur de 110% d'une guerre mondiale donc
beaucoup d'éléments montrent que cette
cette guerre elle va être présente dans
la réflexion sur la décision électorale
et comme on le sait tous l'agenda de
cette guerre est tout à fait indépendant
de l'agenda électoral et jusqu'au
dimanche 6 la campagne s'arrête vendredi
soir la guerre continue et donc on peut
avoir des événements dont il faudra bien
que vous rapportiez l'existence vous
même des journalistes et qui produiront
un effet sur le scrutin pierre jacqmin
il ya une information qui est connu de
tous la proximité entre marine le pen et
vladimir poutine l'admiration qu'elle
lui portait ça se beaucoup d'imagés
d'archivés ressortent mais elle date de
2017 y avait question aussi du
financement de sa campagne électorale
banques hongroises banques russes qui
sont derrière ce financement enfin tout
ça n'a pas imprimé au premier tour mais
on peut imaginer dans l'hypothèse d'un
duel macron le pen que ce soit un des
axes de campagne du président sortant
face à marine le pen oui sans doute
j'espère que ce sera pas le seul parce
que je vous prends pas que ce soit de
cette manière là qu'on combat l'extrême
droite au contact durant son adversaire
même si évidemment ça fera partie de ces
éléments là on a vu dans la première
partie de cette campagne électorale
semble plutôt dans la deuxième partie
même jour à la fin de la partie au
moment où la guerre dont une crème se
déclenche c - jean-luc mélenchon et
marine le pen qui sont accusés de
complaisance vis à vis de l'ami des
routines que eric zemmour qui semble
capter justement les la désapprobation
des français qui avaient vocation à
voter pour lui qui en pâtit le plus
parce qu'il avait commencé à dégringoler
quasiment un parti de mme lagarde
l'enquète fondapol que vous avez dû
comme nous il ya la crainte d'une
ingérence étrangère d'une manipulation
par la russie cette option il ya tout ça
et je trouve que ce qui est d'ailleurs
assez dommage dans cette campagne vous
l'avez s'était dit à plusieurs reprises
il y en a eu véritablement débat
emmanuel macron à verrouiller justement
cette possibilité de devoir se
confronter des idées et ça a été dit par
votre journal estime tout à l'heure je
pense que ça a été un une peut-être une
des erreurs c'est à dire qu'une campagne
politique présidentielle c'est moins la
somme des blessés - l'addition de
propositions telles que beaucoup de
candidats ont fait comme jean luc
mélenchon qui a valorisé tout le temps
c'est 700 propositions c'est vraiment un
projet contre projet et la guerre en
ukraine notamment les rapports qu'on
peut la france pour entretenir avec la
russie par exemple aurait dû le faire
l'objet justement d'un débat se faire
qu'une confrontation de projets à
projets je pense que c'est ça que les
français attendaient les français
attendent moins l'accumulation des deux
propositions du catalogue de
propositions que où est-ce que président
à quoi va servir un président à quoi
sert la france de demain où elle nous
emmène est ce que c'est un rapport du
multilatéral avec les autres pays du
monde est ce qu'on prend en compte les
nouveaux enjeux géostratégiques dans le
monde est ce qu'il faut parler avec le
pakistan avec la russie la chine ou est
ce au contraire on redevient une
puissance fermé comme une trump la
feccom byden continue de le faire ou
comme marine le pen le proposerait ce
qu'au contraire on continue à parler
avec tout le monde malgré effectivement
les rapports détestable qu'on peut avoir
avec la russie aujourd'hui et c'est ça
qui va manquer dans cette période
politique qui aurait dû être l'occasion
malheureusement contenu la situation en
ukraine mais se réduit et une occasion
de parler de puissance à quoi ça sert
une puissance aujourd'hui comment on
utilise la puissance française moralité
macro aurait peut-être dû accepter un
débat
d'avant premier tour quitte à être le
punching balls et aux autres candidats
pierre latry on vous voit réagir
peut-être justement sur la question de
l' influence de ce soit de la guerre en
ukraine soit de là on va dire poutine au
feeling marine le pen sur les électeurs
c'est là dessus que vous vouliez
intervenir
oui je voulais juste dire
qu'effectivement il ya la guerre en
ukraine va avoir une importance dans le
vote d'une partie de l'électorat
notamment chez manu et si les électeurs
potentiels des manuels macron et yannick
jadot ce qui pourrait avoir un impact
notamment pour ceux de yannick jadot
vis-à-vis de la part des positions de
jean luc mélenchon mais je pense
effectivement que marine le pen au
second tour va là la question de ses
liens avec la russie va être évidemment
beaucoup plus importante que ce qui a
été le cas lors du premier tour puisque
c'est effectivement vous l'avez dit
surtout eric zemmour 1 qui a qui a pâti
de ces positions qui étaient aussi très
pro russe et que je pense qu emmanuel
macron ne va pas se priver d'attaquer
marine le pen sur cette question là et
quand on voit l'image désastreuse de
vladimir poutine en france aujourd'hui
quand on voit que le soutien de la
population française va aux ukrainiens
même dans l'électorat de marine le pen
et eric zemmour ça pourrait
effectivement lui coûter cher avec la
petite petit bémol quand même que le
pouvoir d'achat reste pour leur rappeler
le sujet numéro un le sujet principal
est le sujet sur lequel élections le
vote va se déterminer pour la plupart
des gens davantage que la guerre en
ukraine merci merci pierre latry merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
dominique reynié je rappelle le titre de
ce rapport que vous publiez avec votre
fondation
2022 présidentielle de crise et puis une
une des infos de cette fin d'après midi
de cette fin de mercredi après-midi
jean-louis borloo annonce officiellement
qu'ils se rallient à emmanuel macron
sait pas exactement une surprise mais
voilà ça fait partie des infos de 7 de
cette fin de l'après midi on en n'a pas
débattu ça c'est ma décision peut-être
est-ce un signe que ça n'a pas une
importance majeure bref voilà je fais
mon dieu je fais alice soutiennent la
candidate socialiste aujourd'hui je fais
ce faible bruit ça c'est une info je
fais mon auto analyse voyez elle née